There are A LOT of fitness gadgets out there.
In my quest to get fit, I tested 17 of them
over the last few months.
At least one personal trainer I know was a
little bit skeptical.
Yeah, I've been watching these new technologies
come to the market for almost as long as I've
been a personal trainer, they're just tricks
and tropes.
They're not much different than the Bowflex machines
or, to be honest
the original Jane Fonda workout video.
But some of these gadgets that are just coming
to the market do so much more than they used
to do just tracking your activities.
Out of all them, this chest strap was my favorite.
It comes with a robot coach that points the
future -- one where you might not need a human
trainer at all.
And it works like this.
You wear the chest strap so that it can read
your heart rate, and that connects to Moov's
free app that talks to you.
Welcome to Moov heartrate HIIT outdoor running.
Let’s get moving and warm up in Zone 2.
Moov’s computerized coach tells you what
to do at that exact moment, whether you're
running outside, or doing bodyweight exercises
indoors.
Swing your arms faster to get your legs moving
quicker.
Let’s crush this round!
And by reading your heart rate, she knows
how hard you're working - She keeps you honest.
Way to go, you are in the target zone!
Keep pushing!
You’re almost at the end of the round – Don’t
give up!
I've been running for seven years now and
my biggest problem is that I never push myself
hard enough.
I end up going on the same, slow, comfortable
30-minute jog, but he Moov HR Burn blasted
me out of that rut.
By the end of these half-hour exercises, I
was drenched in sweat in a way that I never
am when I work-out alone.
Training with a real person is great, whether
that’s your group instructor,
your coach or your personal trainer.
But humans?  They’re expensive.
For the rest of us, this $60 gadget is all
you need.